this news cycle man this news cycle just
keeps going faster and faster
i was about to report to you that dr
fauci has a new book coming up this book
was going to be called
expect the unexpected 10 lessons on
truth service and the way forward
this was going to be his version of the
cuomo covid book that you released
during the thing
so i was i was gonna report on it i was
gonna give some thoughts and then
no sooner was that announced then the dr
fauci email leak comes out
and now you can't even find the book on
amazon or barnes and noble or any of the
major book sellers
before i had the chance to report on it
it got pulled
a lesson i think to these guys who got a
lot of credit for leading in covet and
it turned out they were wrong about
everything a lesson
wait to write the book write the book a
little bit later or it's not going to
turn out very well for you but there's
actually even stranger
science fiction than dr fauci's ufos
racial health crises and a texas
valedictorians
viral insistence that babies are not
babies
maybe the unborn babies are aliens too
i'm michael knowles this the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from
ross studwell who says michael you
should call
your show the i told you show
but um it's a good idea i mean
i think we're going to have to rename
the show the i told you show because
this week and last week i guess the week
before that
we have been proven time and time again
and you know how much it pains me to say
this
to have been totally right from the very
beginning
and it has been proven that the experts
and the geniuses
were totally wrong and they called us
conspiracy theorists and lunatics and
idiots and it turns out
we were right and it turns out we're
actually right about things even beyond
the coronavirus it's hard so much
winning but
the problem is that's not so much
winning because yeah you're right about
everything you're smarter than these
lunatics you know you're getting these
things more correct but they've got all
the political
power well when you want to defend
yourself one thing i would strongly
recommend you check out
armored republic you know how important
the second amendment is to the
foundation of our country
and how preparing yourself with body
armor is increasingly
important it's not just enough to go on
the offense you got to also have some
defense too
our friends at ar 500 armor have made
buying body armor easy approachable and
affordable what if you are unsure of
what type of
armor you are needing or just need some
pointers based on your needs
they have you covered they have their
independence day sale going on right now
so you can have your order in before the
fourth of july
these sales are up to 50 off select
products so
get them while they last they have rifle
rated bundles starting as low as 99
very important to protect yourself when
you're gonna protect yourself
you're gonna you're gonna have a firearm
and you're going to be able to
you know go on the offense against an
intruder say
you also want to protect yourself that
is the other side of this
best of all they have put together some
packages specifically for listeners of
the daily wire
for everyone go check it out at ar 500
dot com armor.com knowles use code
nolskwles
at checkout for 20 off i hate to say i
told you so
it pains me it hurts me but i will not
just on kovid
obviously we were all completely right
about that and the fouches of the world
were completely wrong
but even on the ufos you remember
everybody was going
absolutely ufo crazy the aliens exist i
had many debates with matt walsh about
this
matt very pro-alien i somewhat
anti-alien
and i said whatever these ufos are i
don't think that it's e.t
i don't think it's martians and people
said michael you're crazy and i said you
know i think
very likely it's our own technology if
it's not our own technology very likely
it's
the technology of a foreign government
or there may be some other explanation
it might be something of an illusion or
something like that but
i think the least likely possibility is
that it's et
well we got the intelligence report out
we got the ufo report from the pentagon
now again you're going to have to take
this somewhat with a grain of salt
because
we're beginning with the premise here
that the government does not always tell
you the truth
when i pointed out that this might just
be our own technology people responded
to me and said michael
the federal government officials say
it's not our own technology and i said
right and they would never lie to you
right
what have we been doing in the past 18
months they would the past five years or
so
the federal government would never lie
about like russian interference in the
election
or uh ukrainian corruption in the united
states
or uh the coronavirus or uh maybe some
other things having to do with 22 they
would never lie about that right
no but but taking this with a grain of
salt here is what the intelligence
report says
they did they first off deny that it's
our stuff
flying in the sky but then they say
that they have no evidence to believe
this is aliens
i suspect if they did have evidence that
it was aliens they might try to leak
that or continue to stoke that
because it would be very sensationalist
it would keep the public enraptured it
would
get people more supportive of spending
money on space force or on defense
spending
but they write quote uh intention
intelligence officials believe at least
some of the aerial phenomena could be
experimental technology from a rival
power most likely russia or china
called it totally called it i said it
from the beginning
the people who were first observing
these phenomena said it wasn't russia or
china
the other genius observers about this as
it was in russia or china i said i bet
it's russia or china
looks as though i'm right in as much as
we can trust the report looks as though
we were right here
our senior official briefed on the
intelligence said without hesitation the
u.s officials knew it was not
american technology maybe maybe it is
maybe it isn't maybe it's a fake out to
russia or china
but he said there is worry among
intelligence officials that china or
russia
could be experimenting with hypersonic
technology why do we believe this well
there is actually a lot of evidence
russia has been investing heavily
in hypersonics believing that that
technology offers the ability to evade
american missile defense technology
obviously it would is it just russia no
china also has developed
hypersonic weaponry and included it in
military parades so it's not even like
we need to rely on the report
to know that china's building this china
has publicly displayed this kind of
technology
the report concludes if the phenomenon
were chinese or russian aircraft
officials said it would suggest the two
powers hypersonic research has far
outpaced american military development
well of course that's the case because
russia and china are investing their
money and focusing on winning wars
in the united states is making glossy
cartoon commercials about soldiers who
have lesbian
mothers who spent their youth growing up
at pride parades so yeah
where you put your resources that's
where you're going to get the payoff
there's no woker
military establishment right now in
bureaucracy than that in the of the
united states
but in terms of this hypersonic
technology china and russia may have a
leg up
the things that they are doing says the
report where they're spending money
you can't help but be concerned about
china's ability to challenge us as i
said in certain places and then
and uh former officials go on they say i
don't want to talk about this in detail
because it poses a national security
threat to acknowledge that
but there are places where china is
frankly doing a better job
right that's a big problem one of the
arguments in favor of this being aliens
is they said
well they're the aircraft are going
faster than the speed of sound
right we know how to do that that yes
there are some aspects of these aircraft
that we don't understand at all that
seems really
quite far ahead of our technology but
the hypersonic thing we do understand
united airlines just bought a bunch of
supersonic jets
the concorde flew for years and years
and years decades and decades ago they
actually stopped flying at what at the
end of the 90s or the early 2000s
so yeah we know how to do this stuff and
the idea that there would be some
advances
in that sort of technology over the past
three decades is not
really surprising if it were aliens it
might actually make us feel better
because
if it is as these reports suggest and as
common sense suggests uh if it is the
case that it's russia and china messing
around with new technology
that seems to put us in a far worse
position even crazier than the belief in
extraterrestrial life to me
is the denial of terrestrial life
what i mean by that is we are so eager
to believe in little green
men flying to us from saturn
but we are so at the same time insistent
on denying that babies are babies right
we can't
think about how gullible we are think
about how stupid we are i'm not talking
about
not talking about us okay i'm not
talking about you and me
who were more correct than dr fauci i'm
talking about
the radicals who refuse to acknowledge
that a baby is a baby
you know if if we went out to some
distant star
and found some distant planet and there
were a little rover that found
one little microscopic sort of vaguely
resembles
life this would be an earth-shattering
event we would be so shocked and amazed
but you can see a baby on an ultrasound
in the womb moving his little hands and
he's got all his little body parts and
we deny that that is a human
as a valedictorian girl in texas
just did and she went viral for it i
hesitated to play
this video because i feel bad for 18
year olds who get too much attention
because 18 year olds are idiots just
sort of by definition
they just don't know even if they
they're intelligent they don't really
know anything especially these days
where the educational system
has been so rotted out so i don't want
to put a spotlight on this girl who is
blabbing incoherently and and
begging for the right to murder her own
child
however it's already gone viral i won't
use her name but take a listen to this
ghastly speech starting in september
there will be a ban on abortions after
six weeks of pregnancy
regardless of whether the pregnancy was
a result of rape
or incest six weeks that's all women get
and so before they realize most of them
don't realize that they're pregnant by
six weeks
so before they have a chance to decide
if they are emotionally
physically and financially stable enough
to carry out
a full-term pregnancy before
they have the chance to decide if they
can take on the responsibility of
bringing another human being into the
world
that decision is made for them by a
stranger
a decision that will affect the rest of
their lives is made by a stranger
i am terrified that if my contraceptives
fail
i am terrified that if i am raped
then my hopes and aspirations and dreams
and efforts for my future will no longer
matter
i hope that you can feel how
gut-wrenching that is
yes we can all feel how gut-wrenching
that is now speaking of
guts and gut wrenching think about
applying that same logic to the little
baby
imagine if a life-changing decision were
made for you by someone else you mean
like by an abortionist or by
a child's mother who would kill him in
the womb yeah
imagine that that'd be pretty bad people
are they're not prioritizing
my life right what about someone else's
life right i don't look
plenty of 18 year olds have stupid ideas
about the world i had plenty of stupid
ideas including on this point i think i
was actually
in favor of legal abortion when i was
18. i'm trying to think when i changed
my mind i was probably
20 or something i mean i you know at
this point i probably would have said i
was pro-abortion
so i feel for her and it's too bad that
she blew it this way i mean it's too bad
that she made such a mess of things
instead of just saying thank you it's an
honor to be valedictorian have a good
life
people are saying the speech was
courageous was not courageous i mean she
lied about what speech she was going to
give apparently there had been some
discussions about whether or not she was
going to address this issue
and it's really sad for her because she
has dedicated
now her achievement to
the the alleged right of mothers to
murder their children in the womb that
is not something that
history is going to look kindly on we
talk about the right side of history
sometimes
you know it's a left-wing line well
if there is such a right side of history
you know certainly on the right side of
justice
people people are not going to look at
this very
kindly uh it shows you though
the level of indoctrination i mean this
was even true
when i was a teenager just the way the
culture not even just the educational
institutions the culture
the the hollywood the mainstream media
certainly the educational apparatus they
all
sort of brainwash you with this idea
that you can't possibly speak out
against it
what is courageous about going out and
saying something that will only receive
one plaudits
by the entire system that's not speaking
truth to power that's speaking power to
truth
but it might take that girl a little bit
longer to realize that
with everything sort of crumbling all
around us it's probably a good idea to
invest
in something physical something tangible
something with value something like
acre gold acre lets you subscribe to
gold bars for as little as
30 a month you pay each month once your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars they will discreetly ship acre
gold to your house acre has a new 100
a month subscription to a 5 gram gold
bar acre ships your gold directly and
discreetly to your door but the big
takeaway here
is that you don't need to come out of
pocket all at once to acquire meaningful
gold over time okay
i know that gold costs more than 30
they've got this great
system where you can really start to
invest
i've always enjoyed investing in
precious metals it's also a good hedge
when the economy and the political
system is looking a little bit kooky
visit getacregold.com knowles right now
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to this url because
acre is giving away a gold bar to
qualify for the giveaway tweet or post
why you should be the recipient mention
at get underscore acre
that is getacre gold.com knowles knwles
thank you aker gold for supporting the
show the valedictorian girl in texas
believes that her most cherished right
is the
fictional constitutional right to murder
her baby
women who have that alleged right forced
upon them recognize that that is not the
case
the ap the associated press recently
spoke with the uyghur exiles
from china the uyghurs are this ethnic
minority and religious minority in china
they're not treated very well by the
chinese government a lot of people are
not treated well by the chinese
government
so one of the more ghastly
policies of the chinese government is is
that of sterilization for sterilization
and forced
abortion so in particular when there was
the one child policy
but also among populations that that
china is trying to kill off like the
uyghurs
and even today where chinese citizens
are allowed to have
two to three babies uh if you have more
than that
the the authorities will come in kick
down your door and kill your kid
in your womb so this is uh from one of
these uyghur women
said i was six and a half months
pregnant the police came
one uyghur and two chinese they put me
and eight other pregnant women in cars
and took us to the hospital
uh this is a woman who's now fled and
she's living in istanbul they first gave
me a pill and said to take it
so i did i didn't know what it was half
an hour later they put a needle in my
belly and sometime after that i lost my
child this is
heart-wrenching stuff especially for
anybody who's ever had a kid
you learn very quickly that the baby
that you're holding in your hands
is the same baby that was in the
mother's belly and when
you have a child when you're about to
have a child
and and you desire that child and you
don't have any desire to kill that child
you think of that child as a baby we
never talk about the royal fetus when
kate middleton is pregnant right we
always talk about the royal baby
well does the baby becomes a baby
because he is desired by his parents
no the baby either is a baby or he's not
a baby in the desire of his parents to
keep him or kill him has nothing to do
with that as absolutely no bearing
on the question this woman obviously
wanted her baby and the baby was
killed by these chinese authorities look
at the birth rate
birth rates are important things to look
at because we talk about ways to save
the civilization save our country well
if you stop having kids then there's no
it doesn't matter how many brilliant
polemics or political philosophies you
come up with if there's not gonna be any
people then you're not gonna have a
country
the birth rate across the xinjiang
region which is the region where the
uyghurs are
fell by nearly half in the two years
between
2017 and 2019. the i guess that's three
years 2017 2018 2019
the most intense drops occurred in
places where
the uyghurs and other minorities are
located
throughout the counties that are
populated by a majority of these
minorities majority minority the birth
rate dropped on average by 43.7
from 2017 to 2018. the birth rate in
counties
populated by 90 or more indigenous
people
dropped by 56.5 on average in the same
year
if that is not a genocide i don't know
what is
but very sad for the uyghur people
obviously it's a horrific thing being
done by the chinese government the
reason i bring it up
is that the mechanism there the
mechanism of that genocide
is the exact same thing that
leftists in america are claiming to be a
sacred right
it's the s there is no difference in the
act what the ccp is doing to the uyghurs
and what this valedictorian in texas is
begging for and pleading for
as her most cherished right it's the
exact same thing
the only difference is consent
right the uyghurs are not consenting to
this and the leftists in america i guess
sort of are even though their free will
is obviously compromised
by vice and madness
there are other things in the world
beyond consent consent is important
but there's also good and evil right and
wrong true and false
if if you are
praying about the what's being done to
the uyghurs by the chinese government
and you're clamoring for your right to
kill your child through abortion
something has gone wrong you're not
seeing the situation
for what it is now this issue in china
is not just a question of abortion
human rights or whatever the new term is
to describe
the universal aspect here there's also a
racial aspect which is that
the chinese government the han chinese
are attacking this other
ethnic group in china the uyghurs
obviously
racial issues are very often a dividing
line of governments and especially in
the united states that's sort of the
main dividing line in america
it's the real weak spot that america's
enemies over the years notably the
soviet union but others
have have tried to uh hit upon because
it it creates tension in the country
so one big racial question that's up
right now is whether or not
we will have reparations for slavery
you've heard this for the first time
in a major presidential race a huge
number of the candidates are saying they
support reparations for slavery
and even joe biden has supported a
commission to talk about whether or not
we should have reparations
so don lemon will go half of tweedle
eastweedledom on cnn
don lemon brings up this question of
reparations and
columbia professor john mcquarter who is
a liberal but is a little more
reasonable as far as liberals go
he goes on the show and he says don
whether or not you want reparations or
not
we've already had them i'm a little wary
of the idea
that we should think of that as a
microcosm for what should happen for
black america because
not because i'm against reparations but
because reparations for black america
already happened starting in the late
60s affirmative action
was reparations people didn't use that
word but that's precisely
what it was the community reinvestment
act of 1977 that forced banks to invest
in inner cities nobody makes a movie
about that but
that was reparations if affirmative
action
didn't help to turn black america upside
down then why do we
fight red tooth claw and nail whenever
anybody
threatens it it created a huge black
middle class
and it created black success of all
kinds that wouldn't have happened
without it i think affirmative action
was a great thing but i do think that it
was a reparation
i love this argument i love the angle
he's taking here because he's saying
look some kind of reparation
is perhaps justified and this was the
opinion of basically
everybody after the civil war right they
said 40 acres and a mule that was going
to be the promise because
you can't just say to a huge number of
people
okay you've you've got your freedom now
but you don't have
any property and you don't really have
many political rights and you've got
people who are
really opposed to you having political
rights and okay so it'll work out fine
right
no it probably won't now should we have
reparations
hundreds of years later uh i think that
argument's a little weaker
but to me the clever argument is we've
already had them
of course and of course we have if
affirmative action if the racially
focused welfare programs of the last 60
years in this country
are not a reparation then what the hell
are they what's the point of them
if they're not a reparation get rid of
them if we're gonna if we're gonna do
something else now
then we absolutely need to scrap all of
those programs
if it's not a reparation why do black
students get preferential treatment when
they apply to college
why are white students and asian
students put at a disadvantage
they have to score higher on the sat
they have to get better grades they have
to do better
than the black students to get into the
same colleges that's a reparation well
okay if it's a reparation
then we've already got it but
what this shows you and this i think is
the brilliance of the quarters argument
here he hasn't even come to this
conclusion explicitly but i think it's
it's implied
the one of the arguments against
reparations is what do you think's gonna
happen we're gonna
okay ten billion dollars there yeah
that's the reparations we're good now
it's all good
no more racial grievance of course not
it's never going to end there's no end
point to that
and the proof of this is we've already
tried it and there was no endpoint to it
now the left tries to lump everything in
with these problems the left
actually views many aspects of our
society notably the criminal justice
system as just an extension of slavery
and jim crow aoc made this point
aoc believes that that the prisons are
basically sort of modern-day slavery
and she thinks it ought to be a very
important goal of justice
to reduce the prison population if we
want to reduce violent crime
if we want to reduce the number of
people in our jails the answer
is to stop building more of them the
answer is to make sure that we actually
build more hospitals
we pay organizers we get people mental
health care
and overall health care employment etc
it's to support communities not throw
them away
so aoc
wants to reduce the total prison
population
there is crime all over this country
the cities are being burned down
left and right do you believe that we
need
fewer people in prison or more people in
prison
seems to me we need more people we talk
about we have mass incarceration
not mass enough crime's going through
the roof
well no michael it's a terrible system
where people are going to jail for
having dime bags of marijuana first of
all that's not true
people are going to jail because they
get plea deals from much more
significant charges
but even beyond that as long as you've
got antifa and blm terrorizing the
streets as long as you've got crimes
spiking in the cities
why on earth would we want fewer people
in prison
if you want less crime you got to put
more criminals in the clink
now this is just common sense here's
another piece of common sense
rock auto rockauto.com is so much easier
than walking into that store
and having a clerk humiliate you because
you don't know all the details of your
car
is your honda michael is your honda the
gt3 c7
or i guess if the clerk were talking to
aoc they would say
aoc is your tesla the super duper
stocked up one or just the one that
prevents you from fixing abuela's roof
there are lots of questions
that you could be asked and you're not
gonna have the answers they're gonna go
in the back they're not gonna have the
part
they're going to come and order the part
online and charge you twice as much
don't
don't do that rockauto.com family
business
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear
like the airlines do why would you spend
up to twice as much for the same parts
they're a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
get the same prices for pros like me and
do-it-yourselfers like you
head on over right now to that very easy
to navigate catalog rockauto.com
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and then write knowles in there
how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you aoc
very focused on justice we need to let
the criminals out of prison she says
this would be justice
aoc does not seem so interested in
justice for her own family so she
tweeted
out just a couple days ago she goes just
over a week ago
my abuela fell ill i went to puerto rico
to see her
my first time in a year plus because of
covid this is her home
hurricane maria relief hasn't arrived
trump blocked money for puerto rico
people are forced to flee ancestral
homes and developers are taking them so
most of this is not true she says that
uh
hurricane maria relief hasn't arrived
that's not true we did send relief
trump blocked money for puerto rico no
he didn't that's not true what happened
is they sent money and then the corrupt
puerto rican officials
took the money and stole it but that's
not even my big problem with this tweet
here's my problem i'm looking at
abuela's house
i don't know if it's an apartment or a
house there's roof problems she's living
in squalor
i would estimate that to fix that roof
costs
i don't know like a thousand dollars or
something like that right because it's a
very small roof
but let's say it's more let's say it's
ten thousand dollars to fix that roof
aoc is a wealthy woman she's a famous
wealthy politician she drives a tesla
she can't fix abuela's roof she that's
that's very wicked that's a that's an
evil thing to let your abuela
why do we have to use the term abuela by
the way does aoc not speak english
the term is grandmother i don't say you
know i was visiting my nonna
the other day you know yes we went we
had a lovely christmas dinner
i just left my uncle's house and then uh
i drove over to
myanmar as a house no we don't do that
because we're americans and we speak
english here
so she's gonna let her her abuela live
in squalor
aoc drives a tesla i drive a honda i was
thinking about buying a nicer car
but the nicer car i was gonna buy would
have been about ten thousand dollars
more than the honda was
so i got ten thousand dollars lying
around because i didn't go buy the i
wasn't even gonna buy a tesla i was just
gonna buy like a slightly fancier car
so i got i got that 10 grand lying
around i would like to fix abuela's roof
i know multiple other people here who
would like to fix abuela's roof so aoc
doesn't want to do it just
please someone send us a wayless address
so that we can fix it but of course aoc
she doesn't want to do that
she actually realized too that she got
caught in this she goes oh no abuela's
fine is that what doesn't look fine
looks like she's living in squalor
no no it's just we just need trump needs
to do it trump huh
that guy's not pregnant that guy's not
going to be president again until august
if recent reports are to be believed i'm
joking i'm joking
i'm joking so
aoc laments this horrible situation for
her
abuela she then laments being a first
generation immigrant
she tweeted out she says i'm a first
generation how dare you speak to me this
way
the problem with that statement is aoc
is not a first generation immigrant
actually jeremy pointed this out to me
aoc responded this way to matt walsh on
twitter and then jeremy pointed out to
me
he said aoc is not a first generation
immigrant her father was born in america
and her mother was born in an american
territory
aoc has been an american citizen
without any question of her being a
first generation immigrant
words have meaning if we are to have
self-government
words need to have meaning i write about
this in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now for pre-order
the connecticut legislature is testing
the meaning of words
the connecticut legislature has passed a
bill that declares racism
a public health crisis
now the bill needs to be signed by the
democrat governor
racism a public health crisis the bill
writes
it is hereby declared the policy of the
state of connecticut to recognize that
racism is a public health crisis
there is established a truth and
reconciliation commission like south
africa
to examine racial disparities in public
health the commission
shall study institutional racism in the
state's laws and regulations impacting
public health
so if if you can this is what's always
been so dangerous about the public
health tyranny of the last year and a
half
more than any other government agency or
government system
public health has basically limitless
power
because the people who run it are
politicians that are by design
unaccountable to the people but they can
claim
that their preferred policies are backed
up by science so there's no arguing with
it or debating it
and so now what they're going to try to
do is is
call everything that they want a public
health crisis
and then once they do that there will be
no one to stop them
okay i see the political utility in this
i see the political utility and trying
to spin
and trying to make words mean things
that they don't mean every politician
does that to some degree or another
if we cannot agree on the most basic
meaning of words
we will not have a country the
self-government relies upon the idea
that there is an objective reality we
have words that
can describe that reality and we
basically agree on what the reality
is and what the words that refer to the
reality mean
if we don't have that we lose our
government
speaking of words losing their meaning
princeton
princeton university considered one of
the top universities in the country
is removing the latin and greek
requirement from its classics major
so you can major in classics classics
right written in latin and greek
but you don't need to read latin and
greek
it's pretty strange how are you going to
read the classics
usually you have to read some books at
least to get a degree well this is being
reported by
ben zeissloft at campus reform who also
writes for the daily wire
the university has changed that classics
requirement
and added a track in race and identity
race and identity which is just a silly
ideological derivation of critical
theory
and it's uh basically just a really easy
uh track for stupid students to follow
when they added these critical theory
sort of disciplines and critical race
theories and derivation of that
it not only poisoned the american mind
in the american university but it
part of the reason it's spread is
because it's easy you don't have to be
very smart to get these kinds of majors
and so for students who were not doing
very well it just gave them an easy out
so they could still graduate from
from university uh
what are we going to do about this sort
of thing what are we going to are we
just going to say well academic freedom
well princeton you know it's private
institution sort of and so they can do
whatever they want i don't think so
the texas gop showing exactly what we
ought to do
the the dallas mavericks run by that guy
mark cuban
that anti-american guy mark cuban who
sucks up to china all the time
mark cuban decided he's not going to
play the star spangled banner on the
court before the game
okay that's his right isn't it he's a
private organization and he no
texas gop came out they passed the
star-spangled banner act star spangled
banner protection act i think is what
it's called
and it requires that the anthem be
played before professional sports games
in texas
uh lest the teams give up their funding
from the state i love that
i love them but michael it's a
regulation on business it's not small
government right i don't like small
government i like limited government i
don't like small government
but it's a use of the political arm of
the yes that's good i like it when
when the people give us political power
i think we should use that political
power use it justly but we should use it
yeah i think that's good
but michael who cares it's just the star
spangled better well who cares the left
cares a lot
maybe the left cares because the left
realized that culture culture matters
maybe actually the same conservatives
who are arguing that we shouldn't
use the government to do this or the
conservatives who say that politics is
downstream of culture we've got to focus
on culture well true
but politics influences culture as well
texas gop showing the way forward here
great stuff i love this and i love that
mark cuban
is going to have to stand for the star
spangled banner he'll at least have to
play the star spangled banner cry
more mark i know he'd rather play the
national anthem of china
well tough tough buddy you're just gonna
have to deal with that and stand up
for the red white and blue then today
we'll be talking about his escape
from new york not his personally but
this sort of conservative movement to
get out of new york because the place is
falling apart
when it comes to exposing the left for
the illogical propagandists that they
are
ben is probably the second best man for
the job no i'm
i'm only sort of telling the truth no
i'm kidding i'm kidding he's really
he's tops if you want to hear from him
you're in for a real treat every
saturday an audio episode of this new
series
debunked is dropping daily wire members
can get the full
10 episode first season over at
dailywire.com if you're not already a
member you get 20 off today with code
debunked
while the discount lasts tomorrow the
audio episode on pro abortion propaganda
drops
then will destroy the left's moral and
scientific
unreasoning for abortion and discuss why
life begins at conception so check it
out tomorrow on this podcast feed
over at apple spotify or whatever your
platform of choice may be
we'll be right back with the mailbag
welcome back to the mailbag first
question from marie
hey michael i've recently had
conversations with people about waiting
until marriage to have sex
other than the bible tells me so why do
you if you do
think that it's better to wait a lot of
people like to argue
like that like cars you should try it
before you buy it
which seems like a valid point at face
value but i i know there's
more to it i would love to hear your
thoughts sincerely minivan
in the peeps lambo on the streets
whoa baby oh my gosh because it's a
family show
cut that out um oh minivan two my peeps
that's that's still
it's still very lurid uh
yes the analogy is true if you consider
yourself an
object to be written do you
or if you consider yourself a human
being then i guess it doesn't hold as
true
it's the same thing as the you know will
you know you go why buy the cow when you
can get the milk for free
like yes that that argument does make a
pretty good point
and uh also one does not want to compare
oneself to a cow
because you're a human being you have
dignity very few people
i've noticed in our pop culture uh wait
until marriage
you know i was an atheist for ten years
and sure behaved like one so i'm
speaking i guess a little bit from
experience here uh the people i know who
waited until marriage to have sex
seem happier with their decision than
the people who did not
just speaking anecdotally just from
people i know but
there's a line in in glengarry glen ross
a terrific play
by uh uh gosh what's his name it's one
of the great playwrights david mamet
in glengarry glen ross the al pacino
character ricky roma says
you'll regret the things you don't do
huh
he doesn't have you who else you regret
the things you don't do and a lot of
people believe this a liberal friend of
mine said this the other day
in my experience that's not true in my
experience you regret the things you do
do that you shouldn't have done
i don't regret many things that i didn't
do i've done a lot of things i guess
but i certainly have many regrets
about things that i did do i shouldn't
have said this i shouldn't have acted in
this way
i shouldn't have ignored this thing i
shouldn't have this said that and the
other thing
we do have regrets about these things
that we do
i think that
your inclination here is that it's a
good thing to wait until marriage and
that's something very special and it's
it's
something that you won't be able to get
back you can you know you move on plenty
people get married if they
you know had sex before marriage by the
vast majority of people
but you can never get that back so i
would hold on to that
thing that's that's quite valuable and i
think that men will appreciate that
and i think that you will appreciate
that and i think that if
if your guy also hasn't had sex before
marriage if somehow that works out
then uh you'll have something really
special because you'll share that
together from victor hey mr knowles i
was listening to one of your all
accesses the other day
and i heard that you don't believe in
the apparitions of medjugorje
this is a marian apparition that some
catholics believe in
they believe that mary appeared at this
place medjugorje
um and then some people are skeptical of
that i know many people who have gone
and had special experiences my old
priest and my father for example
my family's always believed in it i
never really questioned it
you're someone that i really respect
because of your intelligence and so i
was wondering why you didn't believe in
it
also what are your thoughts on gara ban
garanda badal i don't actually know how
to pronounce this but it's a
spanish apparition site or alleged
apparition site sincerely victor
without going too in the weeds here i
believe
that there have been miraculous
apparitions
right notably there was the the
apparitions at fatima which i believe in
about 100 years or so ago i believe that
these i believe
in the apparition of our lady of
guadalupe which happened to juan diego
here in the americas
and i see the the tilma of this
miraculous image and i
i believe that i believe in lots of
these things but i'm not superstitious
you know i don't just believe in
anything without any
bit of evidence um i think sometimes
people are confused they think that
religious people are the most
superstitious people on earth i think
actually we're the least superstitious
because we do apply rigor to these
things you know reason and faith
working together so when it comes to
medjugorje
i just noticed that unlike at fatima the
alleged seers at medjugorje did not
dedicate themselves to the church did
not become nuns or brothers or priests
they enriched themselves and they bought
really fancy homes and they
appear to have made
very narrow partisan
perhaps self-serving political claims as
though they this we
were mentioned by the the uh our lady by
the the blessed virgin who's referred to
as gospel
in the medjugorje apparition uh in some
cases
things that they're saying that the
gospel told them seemed to contradict or
at least
not be present in any sort of christian
tradition
ever so it just seems a little
difficult to believe to me and the
length of time that this has gone on the
financial considerations here the
collaboration with
the at that time ruling communist party
in the area i just
i just don't bite i'm not saying it's
not possible i do not buy it as for
uh garanda badal i i don't know but it
seems
more worthy of belief to me and the
position of the church is
uh is open on this right i mean the
church has not said that this is worthy
of belief they've the pope francis
recently opened some questions about
medjugorje
but we'll have to find out as for me i'm
pretty skeptical from
jillian hey so i saw your show last week
and was thinking about the mailbag
question with the man whose wife got an
abortion due to rape
i'm right now in a situation like that
oh it's terribly sort of hear that
i was at a party about two months ago
didn't make the best decisions and had
some things happen
non-consensually to me oh gosh awful
it's making me a little less sure
in my decision to get an abortion i have
one scheduled for next week
i wouldn't normally get an abortion
because i wouldn't consensually make the
decision to have sex before marriage
i feel like if i have this kid i'm
giving up my chances of finding a good
man given that i had my virginity stolen
and had a kid consequently i feel
hopeless thank you for any advice that
you would give
i'm terribly sorry that you find
yourself in this situation where you had
this terrible experience
do not get the abortion listen to me
listen very closely do not get the
abortion
you will regret it for the rest of your
life you will regret it every single day
do not do it it seems like the easy way
out because you think if you get the
abortion then it's as if you you never
had this horrible experience you never
had a child but it doesn't erase that it
just
adds another evil to these to this evil
that that was perpetrated on you
and and you you won't be able to
convince yourself otherwise you won't be
able to rationalize it
what you can do if you don't feel able
to raise the child
is give the baby up for adoption there
are 32 couples in the united states
number of changes a little bit something
like 32 couples in the united states
for every baby that is put up for
adoption
do not do not do this you
will both for the
i mean don't do not do this because the
act itself would be intrinsically evil
and you know would be terrible for the
baby but
for you just for you do not you will
i know multiple people who have had
multiple abortions for that matter
and it really wrecks them
do not do this
uh i wish you the best of luck i can
pray for you
uh but do not let the the sort of fear
and anxiety and shame or whatever
lead you to commit something that will
only increase your fear and your anxiety
and your shame you're afraid that some
man isn't going to like you now because
you had this horrible thing happen to
you and and you know then you had a baby
and either raised it or gave it up for
adoption
uh first i don't think a man is gonna
think that way
and not not a good man anyway but if
you're worried about the opinion of the
man well what about the opinion of the
man if you go ahead and have the
abortion
do not do it do not do not do it
uh feel free to reach out again happy to
answer more questions
from camille dear michael i'm a single
woman in my mid-20s
and i want to ask your opinion on dating
apps personally i hate the apps
i'm a christian and do genuinely believe
god has a plan uh
and so and someone for me but
i do i have to be on the apps to find
them or will god make it happen
or is being on dating apps a god helps
those who help themselves situation
sincerely dating
mishap man that's the signatures are
getting
getting much better i never was on the
apps
just missed it sweet little elise and i
got back together before the apps came
out
or before they were really popular and
so i never had to deal with that
some people use the apps just to hook up
i guess a lot of people do that
some people use the apps to find their
spouses i've been to multiple weddings
of people who met on the dating apps
if you don't like the dating apps i
don't think you need to be on them
but you do need to meet men elsewhere
you do need to meet guys at the church
or at
the bar or at work or at
some social circle or friend of a friend
or set up on a blind date so
you got to do that i suppose now the
culture is such that people do generally
meet on the apps
but yeah i i don't think i would have
enjoyed being on the apps there's
something very
you're really putting yourself out there
i mean it's just like everybody is
putting out
a a classified ad and so there's
something kind of clinical about that
there's something that i don't i don't
particularly care for
but but you know people can meet and
have have great
uh relationships and marriages out of it
so i i don't think the apps are evil in
themselves but there are other options
the thing is you can't use your aversion
for the apps
as an excuse not to date at all you just
need to if you're not going to use the
apps you need to make sure that you
say hey friend set me up on a date with
somebody hey
you know local group that i'm a member
of
let's hang out more often let's go to
the this dinner let's go to this bar
let's go to this let's go to that
the other thing from michael oh princess
gloriosis
in today's episode you spoke of january
6th in reference to the relatively
small-scale riot that took place earlier
this year
might i suggest that we conservatives
stop using the term january 6th
to reference that event i believe that
in using that language to talk about
that day we are feeding the leftist
attempt to cement in our minds their
comparison
to september 11th by having us use that
date as a reference point they are
controlling
words and controlling minds instead
shouldn't we refer to it
as the acts of destruction at the
capitol in january
or something else appropriately creative
what are your thoughts
thanks for all that you do fellow
sicilian american catholic new yorker
named michael wow
what a guy you're totally right
i've sometimes used it i hope i haven't
used it too often in an earnest way i
sometimes will say in january 6 you know
and on the insurrection
but i think you're right we should not
refer to january 6. it's there's no
comparison
between january 6. there's no comparison
between the capital riot
and september 11th there's no comparison
between the capital riot and pearl
harbor
there's no comparison between the
capital riot and the blm riots of 2020.
the blm riots were much much much worse
and the focus on the capital riot is
a distraction in a way to for the left
to get rid of their
their culpability i also love your
reference
which is to my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now
for pre-order i think you're totally
right
it's a very good part if i could expand
the book in a new edition i would
include that
from daniel hi michael is a strong
proponent of a justice-centered
conception of self-government
such as that which is found in the
federalist 51 when madison said
justice is the end of government you've
often stated that we shouldn't be afraid
of using the power of government to
regulate or even ban things that
undermine the property of government
as a result you've come under fire by
many libertarian leading neocons
for seeming to be a proponent of in
their view catholic theocracy if your
preferred policies were to reach their
logical end states
what would you say to these people would
you really prefer their constitution or
chiseled and two stone tablets on mount
sinai as opposed to being written in the
pennsylvania state house thanks love the
show daniel
no it's not that i i wish that our
constitution were totally different than
it is
and we're a theocracy and i just wish
people would
read the constitution read the
federalist and read american history
because my view which is now being
derided by the libertarians and the
neocons
as theocratic and authoritarian my view
is frankly more liberal than the view of
the founding fathers
during the founding at the time of
ratification
the definition of a felony was that you
would hang you would hang for it
right i'm not saying that we need to go
that extreme in criminal justice
at the time of the founding there were
state established churches
different states actually had their own
church establishments
i'm not going that far and saying we
need to have these specific church
establishments because frankly i don't
like the ones they had
but what i am pointing out and this is
one of the things i talk about in my
upcoming book speeches controlling words
controlling minds
is that this sort of thing
exists the church always has some
relationship to the state religion
always has some
relationship to government and our
politics is such that
uh you know either we're gonna use the
power or our
opponents are gonna use the power and i
would just assume we use the power when
the people give it to us i want to try a
little experiment before we go
speechless
speechless
i just wanted to see that's just wanted
to break it before the weekend
see you guys everybody have a good
weekend
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin